hi i'm harrison backrack i typically say
i'm a software engineer during
introductions but
chances are high that you're a software
engineer too so
i guess i bake but i guess everyone is
baking right now so
to clarify it i bake holla here's some
holla before it's edible and
here's some hollow wallets edible if you
haven't heard of holla
that's it's like that scene at the end
of tangled where all the kids get
together and braid rapunzel's hair so
it's not dragging everywhere
but unlike hair it's not gluten-free
i actually had a frame from tangled in
here but
i was worried about the stream being
taken down so that's why you have some
generic stock footage
so if you're like me you've probably
gotten really passionate about
programming at some point
for some reason and wanted to do a side
project
cool me too happens to me all the time
and things always kind of fall apart
right
first you have an idea a lot of us are
spending a lot of time
indoors all of a sudden so what if you
were to start an indoor plant collection
except if you're like me you forget to
water these things or forget which plant
needs what sort of light and
all of a sudden you go from this to this
don't think anyone needs this kind of
vibe in their home right now
so can software help uh i mean
let's be real probably not software can
be pretty bad
but hey maybe you know i've been looking
to make something in my spare time
i'm primarily a front-end developer but
i've been hearing about
rust web server projects like actics and
rocket
maybe i can make a web app or something
yeah
yeah you'll be able to upload pictures
of your plants over time
you'll be able to give them names you'll
tell
it'll tell you when they need to be
watered which soil type
they need and where to find that soil
tons of features great
so you get started and work on it until
three am and you get it to the point
where you can create a plants and
you deploy it to heroku and the
automated tests
run on push and sometime passes
and now that thing that was so much fun
for an evening is a stub of a program
and you've lost
all interest or enthusiasm so i feel
like this is probably a
familiar experience for a lot of you
it's a very familiar experience for me
so what happened we're gonna come back
to that at the end of this talk but
first let's talk a little bit about rust
i forget how i found out about rust but
i was intrigued as soon as i got the
pitch
i really like powerful static type
systems which is
funny because all of the languages i use
daily are dynamically typed
though maybe i've just been burned too
many times by my own silly mistakes
who knows so i'd read the rust book a
few times before
off and on but i'd never really made
anything with it
partly because i didn't know how to
start and partly because i was
intimidated
but eventually i saw how easy it was to
make command line applications
and that got me working my first rus
program root
side note thanks to all the people who
made this section of the site
about what to make with rust i went to
the homepage for the first time
for the first time about a year after
initially being introduced to rust
not knowing what to actually build and i
found this information super useful
getting up and running on my first
project
right so this is about solo projects so
let's talk about the solo project of
mine that actually worked
root or if you want to call it rut is a
pretty straightforward program
think of it like tree but instead of
directories and files it works on data
for example you can input some json that
you might
be using to represent a tree of some
sort
here we have a root node with the name
cool a single child node with the name
beans and a single grandchild node with
the name
man but that's kind of hard to see so
root takes that json and converts it
into a diagram like this
cool beans man
the reason i'm talking about root is
that it took almost two months to get it
into its current state
if you're thinking that's a long time to
make a program to do that
i think you're right i'm very much a
beginner when it comes to rust and it's
very possible that many of you could get
this done in a single evening
now i've done small one-night projects
before i made
a widget for making digital flowers to
send to people
i made a dumb two-headed version of
snake with terrible controls
and both were fun they fall into the
same issues that
come with their gardening app from
earlier i never came back to them
so after working on root for weeks and
weeks
i started asking myself why did this
project turn out differently
what was different well it became a
habit
for a lot of us side projects are
something that we want to do in the
abstract
but have trouble doing in the moment if
you've ever come up with
new year's resolutions and almost
inevitably failed those resolutions
that concept might be familiar to you
and that's probably most of you assuming
you had any
so what goes into a successful habit
firstly you have to do it of course
that's
a lot easier said than done
now we're about to step into a big vat
of psychology research and i want to
give a huge disclaimer that i'm a
software
engineer not a psychologist or a mental
health professional
i'm also not a doctor nor lawyer and
it's kind of a bummer because
both of those careers are much easier to
explain to your parents
so in prepping for this talk i read this
paper called promoting habit formation
and in it i found this super academic
sounding quote
intentions to act are significant
precursors of initiation of behavior
but intention translation is imperfect
what the heck does that mean well just
because you want to do something
and you know that that thing that
and you know that you want that thing to
be done
doesn't mean that you'll actually do it
when the opportunity arrives
there are a lot of reasons why people
abandon projects but a major one is not
feeling satisfied
now this may seem silly to say out loud
but how satisfied you feel by
working on a project is a big factor in
whether or not you'll stick with it
if building a project building your
project isn't satisfying
you might want to reflect on that for a
bit why did you think it would be
satisfying
if it was satisfying before what changed
not every minute is going to be super
fun
of course but if it feels really dull
for a while
it may make sense to step back and
consider how to address that or
how to move on to something that might
be more satisfying for you
one thing to note here is that you can
encourage your satisfaction
you may not think about how much you
improve on a skill while working on a
project
but that reflection can be super
uplifting and help you see
value in the work that you've already
done now it all starts with a good goal
what do you want to do you'll often come
up with a simple goal at first
when starting a new project you might
write it down or just have it in your
head
but the work between you and your goal
may grow
this is often how things get
unsatisfying no longer feels like the
work that you're doing is
actually progressing you towards that
goal which is the thing that got you
into this
into the first place coming up with
unrealistic goals is
really easy for example aiming to catch
all pokemon is a ludicrous goal to start
out with
now i feel bad for making fun of a child
but ash ketchum is an absolute fool
do you know how many kinds of pokemon
there are almost 900
so let's say we have some realistic goal
how do we make sure we actually do the
work
one common idea in habit formation is
something called automaticity
which is basically the act of doing
something automatically without
meaning to do it or even being aware of
it for example
for some of you flossing your teeth is
often an automatic
action that you don't actively plan out
or think about
now you probably can't write code as
unconsciously as you can floss your
teeth
but you can start that way that is you
can't write a test without thinking
about it
but you can sit down in front of your
computer and open up your editor pretty
automatically
so when should you work on your project
it's very common to pick a fixed time to
start working on something
for example i will go to the computer at
7 pm
but fixed times aren't really how we
structure a lot of our day
instead our day is broken up by events
into periods of activity
you take a shower you clean up the table
you finish eating dinner
the gaps between these periods are
really significant and tend to stick to
your mind much better
these are the times to schedule working
on your project
but when those events happen what do you
do even when you remember to work on a
project
starting can be daunting in order to
make a habit
having a plan helps a lot the research
is pretty clear here
there's one type of plan that's super
helpful called implementation intentions
however that name is a pain to say so
i'm just going to call them
if then plans they have a form like this
if i encounter x then i will do y in
order to reach goal z
let's say you want to start a habit of
drinking more water
an if then plan that might help is if i
get out of the bed in the morning
then i will fill my water bottle and put
it on my desk
the idea is to get simple tasks into
your routine so that the harder tasks
like remembering to drink throughout the
day get easier
for software projects getting your
environment set up like opening up your
editor and project tracker
can make starting work a lot less scary
now in working on your habit there are
likely going to be some struggles
whether it's difficulty in building the
habit in the first place
frustration when writing code or
uncertainty not on how to make important
architectural decisions
you can create what are called coping
plans on how to deal with these issues
when they crop
up research has found that coping plans
when applied to physical exercise had a
dramatic effect on the endurance of
those habits
of those in the study that made specific
plans on
when where and how to exercise two
months later
around 44 were still performing at least
an hour and a half of exercise
per week however for those who had made
coping plans
71 were still working out that much
forming concrete plans on how to deal
with these roadblocks is super valuable
for success
but also for mental health there very
well may be times when
working on your project where you feel
really useless or stupid
but these are neither accurate nor
helpful thoughts
programming can be a really demoralizing
hobby imposter syndrome is rife within
our industry and those feelings are
often compounded for underrepresented
engineers
i wasn't able to find much research on
coping plans that might apply to side
projects
but in my experience these were super
helpful
first talk with people talking with
people engineers and
non-engineers alike can be a huge relief
and put things in perspective
and of course it's fun i think we could
all use a little bit of fun right now
secondly find some nice communities
online
in addition to being a great place to
ask questions people working on similar
things can often understand your
frustrations
in a deeply validating way i've had a
bunch of super great interactions on the
rust discord for example
that said there are a lot of not nice
communities online i remember i asked a
question on tree traversal on stack
overflow
and the first comment was stop doing
this and rust
number three just step away from the
computer oftentimes
all you need is a bit of distance from
what you're working on to help clear
your mind and relax you
not only that but i found that most of
the time i figure out a tricky problem
when i'm washing dishes or
about to fall asleep now with all these
suggestions
there's one thing that i'll advise
against and that is setting external
rewards for yourself
say for a little extra dessert if you
work a bit
a little bit longer these have actually
been shown to
reduce intrinsic motivation
the risk is that the rewards can often
become the goal
in and of themselves or that the rewards
mean less and less
over time the goal the rewards also tend
to have less of an effect if you have a
very high awareness of them
and we're talking about solo projects
here so that seems very likely
now there's a very common acronym smart
that is referenced a lot in articles on
successful habit building and goal
setting it was initially introduced by
this guy named george t
doran a consultant and director at the
washington water power company in an
article intended for managers on
how to set corporate objectives but
since its introduction
the ideas have gone through a few
changes that better align with personal
goal setting for individuals
while they weren't derived from academic
research they are still a very useful
tool that align with
many of the conclusions from various
studies on habit formation anyway
what are smart goals a smart goal is
specific
it's very clear what the problem is and
if that if your project is intended to
solve a problem
it's very clear what needs to get done
or what you need to build
a smart goal is measurable meaning it
should be clear what's required for it
to be workable
or how close it is to becoming workable
notice i didn't say done
more on that later
a smart goal is achievable it's
something that isn't too far outside the
realm of possibility
i'd love to build a laptop from scratch
for example but for me
that's not exactly realistic a sparkle
is relevant to you
it needs to be something that you care
about something that motivates you
it's something that's hard it's really
hard to put a lot of time into something
that is not directly meaningful to you
lastly
a smart goal is time-bound now in most
indications of smart this refers to a
sort of due date but
that often doesn't apply to side
projects it may never be truly done
additionally due dates often create
unnecessary stress and
this is something that should be
enjoyable instead i'd like to think as
time-bound as referring to your
engagement with the project on a
day-to-day level
limit your habitual time instead of your
total time
so let's see how smart connects to root
first the initial goal was just to write
a program that made drawing those
those tree diagrams from an easy to type
input
the project expanded beyond that
afterwards of course but the initial
idea was very focused
as i went through adding features to
root i really only thought about
everything one small step at a time this
meant that as i wrote more code
the proctors felt really real and was
directly measurable i could literally
count the number of things that i had
added
so this sort of measurement elegantly
translates to filing issues
creating tickets or however you like to
do task tracking
this can be as simple as a list of a
piece of paper which is what i used or
it can be as sophisticated as
an integration with like github issues
or a clubhouse project
another natural way to measure progress
is with semantic versioning
or whatever versioning scheme you might
elect to use each release is a concrete
indication of progress
whether it is a feature edition a bug
fix or something else entirely
both ticket tracking and semantic
versioning serve as reminders to
recognize
achievements that you made along the way
which is very easy to forget
especially when the intermediate product
of your project
doesn't feel very impressive when i
started planning root
i kept scopes small i wasn't going to
have any command line options
i would it would do one thing and only
one thing and even that was too hard
starting in rust was so difficult that i
had to make an initial prototype in ruby
my primary language
root as a project felt very useful to me
it came out of the very real issue
that communicating the specifics of tree
data structures
is super hard i deal with trees a lot at
work
and talking about various corner cases
with specific tree structures
was always super challenging in addition
to the problem domain
root gave me the opportunity to learn
about parsers as well as rust
both of which i had been partially
exposed to but hadn't really been able
to sink my teeth into
that prototype from earlier also aided
the motivation on continuing with rust
as it showed that switching to rust
dropped the execution time
from 200 milliseconds to 5 milliseconds
the static type system also caught a
number of bugs that would have been a
real pain
later on so when working on root
i would really only spend a few hours a
night and only two to three nights a
week
when i got stuck or frustrated on a
problem i would give it a solid attempt
but if that wasn't enough i would take a
break or stop on it for the day
typically i would continue thinking
about the problem in the back of my mind
and
when i came back to it my frustration
was replaced with excitement
and i would end up solving it very
quickly most of the time anyway
in addition to the smart attributes i
just mentioned i found a few other
things really really helpful
showing what i was working on to other
people was very encouraging
even when they're even when they weren't
super impressed
it still made what i had made more real
to me
celebrating victories also made the work
more fun for example
i track downloads on crates io and i
still very vividly remember passing 50
downloads and
being wowed that anyone else might find
what i made useful
so we're equipped to look at what
happened earlier now with our gardening
project
firstly the scope of the project just
ballooned
what started as a way to track caring
for plants became something much bigger
learning rust is also a big challenge
and creating a web application is no
small feat
in addition to learning rust we also
needed to create an authentication
system
we needed to set up how to handle assets
we needed to
to deploy to some server all of that
takes time before we can get up and
running
working for all those hours sure was fun
but it's not sustainable
you end up exhausted the next day and
associating all of that exhaustion with
all the work that kept you up also
one thing missing from the story is
anyone else no talking with friends to
bounce ideas off of
no chatting online when running into
roadblocks working alone is certainly
possible but it's a tough path to follow
all of this is well and good but i do
need to point out a bunch of things
because
well i don't want people to yell at me i
fear being yelled at so much i even
named my
now abandoned ultra depressing comic
series please stop yelling online
really anyway
asterisks firstly don't feel like
watching
after watching this talk that you ought
to do with programming side project
it's not for everyone it's not even for
me a lot of the time that's okay
you can have other hobbies i imagine a
good deal of you write software for your
job
if you don't want to bring that home
then don't another thing
right now we're living through a
historic global pandemic that has
dramatically impacted most of our lives
not only that but people are becoming
even more aware the very
present problem of police brutality
against black people in america
as a result you might feel demotivated
to work on a side project right now
even if you have tons and tons of free
time that's okay
side projects are optional also you
might follow this advice
start a project and abandon it that's
okay
this stuff isn't a silver bullet no
study about any of this stuff is 100
written anywhere
that doesn't say anything about you
stuff happens
lastly again please don't yell at me i'm
very weak and i will be
super sad so in conclusion
make a plan not a schedule build
something that you care about
think small and be kind to yourself
i want to thank everyone uh that was
involved in
uh setting up ruskoff i also want to
thank my parents as well as my partner
and marie
everyone has been super helpful in
getting this talk to this stage
um if you want to follow me online my
website is holoscript.com that's with
the ch
and uh and my twitter is harryb so
thank you